[Música]
en el sur de China escondido entre las
colinas de UNAM se encuentra el pueblo
pugüey con 200 habitantes
aquí es donde habría nacido el niuhu una
forma de escritura única en el mundo
durante siglos fue un secreto conocido
exclusivamente por las mujeres estuvo a
punto de desaparecer
ahora kushing dedica su vida el estudio
de esos caracteres
[Música]
a diferencia del mandarín el newshu se
escribe en forma de rombo Entonces el
trazo es alargado Es agraciado como una
mujer y solo tiene cuatro elementos de
base el punto los trazos verticales
inclinados y arqueados
sucio justo
también se habla en el dialecto local
pero solo las guardianas de Este
lenguaje dominan la escritura y la
lectura de textos
hushing es la más joven de ellas
es una herencia muy valiosa que nos
llega de generaciones anteriores de
guardianas del nishu
Espero poder transmitirlo a la
generaciones futuras
también Es toda una cultura
con canciones tradicionales y bordados
en este museo las autoridades locales
exhiben la artesanía newxo
100.000 visitantes vienen cada año a
conocerla
en esa época las mujeres estaban
oprimidas su único medio de comunicación
Era ese lenguaje es Muy conmovedor
en esta región rural las mujeres no
aprendían a leer ni escribir el mandarín
entonces gracias al New shu podían
intercambiar mensajes de forma discreta
a menudo escribían sobre objetos
pequeños fáciles de transportar para
poder llevarlos dentro de sus mangas
como sobre estos abanicos
los textos eran considerados demasiado
íntimos y debían ser quemados o
enterrados con sus autoras entonces Los
Originales como este cuaderno son muy
raros
aquí dice mi hermana está casada ya no
vive con nosotros Será muy difícil
volver a verla según la tradición las
mujeres casadas no tenían derecho a
salir libremente sólo podían reunirse en
ocasiones especiales
esos textos narran el sufrimiento de las
mujeres y la solidaridad entre ellas es
la esencia misma del niushu
no tienen ningún vínculo de parentesco
se llevan 50 años de diferencia
pero son como hermanas unidas por un
juramento de amistad la mayor aprendió
el newshua hace 80 años a través de su
abuela cuando ella me lo enseñó pudo
enseñárselo a mis amigas teníamos mucho
cuidado de no hablar sobre nuestros
textos en público Los muchachos no
sabían nada
n una vez a la semana para conversar
leer y como hoy improvisar algunas
líneas
para Sushi aprender mushu ha sido
liberador le dio el valor necesario para
dejar a su esposo en un contexto rural
donde el divorcio todavía está mal visto
me di cuenta de que las mujeres deben
ser independientes y tener el derecho de
tomar sus propias decisiones
mi ex esposo y yo nos llevábamos mal
entonces decidí terminar mi matrimonio
ahora la enseñanza del newshu está
regulada por las autoridades locales
en el Museo
da clases a alumnas de la región aquí el
trazo va hacia la izquierda aquí hacia
la derecha
con 60 años espera encontrar una
heredera en la próxima generación
hay que trabajar muy duro para tener el
honor de ser una guardiana del nushu
hay que dominar la escritura el canto y
la lectura
pero para estas jóvenes alumnas aprender
newshu Es complicado
No es tan fácil de memorizar como los
caracteres del mandarín Y aunque vivo
aquí no conozco bien el dialecto local
Entonces los cantos son difíciles de
pronunciar
actualmente esta forma de escritura ha
dejado de ser un secreto pero sigue en
peligro de desaparición solo seis
mujeres chinas son consideradas
guardianas del Nicho
[Música]